foreign
s broke the legs of these people libyans
are giving us water and food it is
Tunisia who put us here but it is the
libyans who have helped us
[Music]
not authorities that these migrants are
supposed to be removed from the border
points because they have infiltrated
illegally we hope the Tunisian
authorities will protect them and
contact the red crescent and other
humanitarian organizations in order to
give some help and protection to these
migrants
[Music]
the tennesseans are the ones who bought
his hair we should go and beg the
Tunisian so that they will take us back
or they should return us we went and
spoke and pleaded with them they said we
should go back to Libya but we haven't
been to Libya before why should we go
back there
[Music]
in our home they came they police they
enter they've been out they told us to
enter we thought that they are going to
rescue us they came and abandoned us yet